a lot of people in our audience we got a
young crowd here and they use Craigslist
a lot of people here leaves Craig's
Destin well I thought once again once
again we should help our audience
members make a sale or connection by
doing them the favor of showing some of
their craigslist ads right here on the
show and getting it out on national
color
[Applause]
this connection me at the Sherman Oaks
Mall on Sunday you livin female between
18 and 94 for sale shirt I haven't taken
off since I was 8
hey guys looking for a woman on
Craigslist then sorry I'm out of your
league
one a better career can't help you there
but I will have sex with your wife
for sale tickets to Madonna concert meet
me tomorrow at the corner of Sepulveda
and 1985 god with a million dollars
seeks woman who thinks parking tickets
are dollars
seeking classy lady into thoughtful
conversation and drinking home brewed
beer or just give me money from here and
finally looking to hire dependable
office workers who haven't seen Austin
Powers yet I do a great impression of
them and would like to dust it off again
yeah baby
yeah you're welcome